hey guys how's it going so we've been
chatting a lot about the iphone 7 rumors
and I got a really great response from
you guys as far as what you thought
about the headphone jack a lot of you
guys were really upset and you didn't
want the headphone jack you removed one
of the latest rumors that I've just come
across I know this has been talked about
for quite some time but it looks like
Apple is going to release a 4-inch
iPhone this is a new information but a
few things have happened that might
confirm that this actually could
potentially be true the original data
they're supposed to have the press
announcement was going to be March 15
but if that's been now pushed to March
21st some are saying that the push back
is due in part because of the craziness
that Apple has been involved with the
whole FBI lawsuit scandal whatever you
guys want to call it that's a whole
nother story but a long story short
basically the FBI wants Apple to create
a backdoor in their iOS system so that
if they ever need to get access to
someone's phone whether it's a court
order or there's some reason that they
need to have access to that phone
they'll be able to do it and Apple is to
provide the software to do that Apple
says no we're not doing that there was a
huge open letter by Tim Cook so here it
is message to our customers it says the
US government has demanded that Apple
take an unprecedented step which
threatens the security of our customers
we oppose this order which has
implications far beyond the legal case
at hand I think you guys might check
that out I'll put a link in the
description so you can sort of read over
the full letter and why Tim Cook feels
that this is so important and since this
letter came out on February 16th a lot
of companies have sort of got behind
Apple and shown support as well we're
here to talk about today is more iPhone
rumors so like I said that they've
shifted the event it was supposed to be
March 15th
thank you BuzzFeed it's already been
rumored they planned unveil the next
generation of the iPad a smaller iPhone
man an iPhone se a 4-inch display a
faster chip and also on board which is
exciting because I think a lot of people
that have the smaller phones and then
they really do like the smaller phones
having support for Apple pay which has
been extremely life-changing for me as
far as traveling goes because you
basically take your phone you put your
little finger over the fingerprint
scanner and you go like this done you've
just paid for whatever it is that you're
ready to purchase they're also talking
about a new selection of Apple watch
fans which I am so excited about because
I didn't think that I'd be so obsessed
with changing my Apple watch bands as I
am I might have a problem let's see if
we can find any possible Apple watch
2016 come on Apple to update its watch
in mid-march
come on give me something good that's
not new that's not new I really like the
rose gold because it was a rose gold
aluminum face so it wasn't the okay
25,000 rose gold watch which if anybody
bought that you're you're an idiot
you're an absolute it one thing that I
am looking forward to in the latest
update on the Apple watch is you'll be
able to use multiple watches so there's
a selection on there where you can
choose which Apple watch you're
currently wearing because right now if
you want to switch this Apple watch out
for the rose gold or another color you
have to completely unlink this watch
from your phone format it relink the
other one and then backup all of that
data from this watch and it's kind of a
process so it technically is not worth
it oh here it is this is talking about
our year develop in the developer Vedas
this is the software allows for multiple
Apple watches to be synced to an iPhone
in addition to new functionality in the
Maps app the problem is I don't ever
actually use Apple Maps I end up using
Google Maps because Apple Maps ends up
taking me into a ditch somewhere so I
usually don't use that but if I'm going
on short trips and things like that
where I kind of do have a general sense
of where I'm going I like to use it
because it does connect and work really
well with the Apple watch so if I'm
driving it's like hey turn left turn
right what else do we have
orange screen just leaked Charlotte
tornado 3d touch insight
when was this posted February 27th what
to say today's February 27 chase sweet
mother of iPhone oh boy iPhone se iPhone
or 5se iPhone 6s slaked photo claimed to
show it next to the Abu for inches but
it would have upgraded features okay
we've already talked yes we've discussed
this we discussed this yes yes yes
move from the top to the side okay yep
yep we'd like that we would like that
my it might these are all like oh it
might have well it might I guess thus
the rumor you are great I'm following
you on Twitter not logged in what do you
guys think about this what do you what
do you think what do you think doo doo
doo doo doo I Phone 7 let's see if
there's any news about iPhone 7 massive
4-inch phone leaks revealed wait I'm
sorry
massive four-inch unveiled a 4-inch
iPhone 5se and thanks to leaks from
bloomberg as well as Apple special sites
we know almost everything which looks
capable of shaking up the market look at
that that's it that's it
5s see drawings nearly identical to 5s
slightly curved edges I'm not saying
anything because I don't have anything
to say I'm just looking
besides these design nearly identical to
the 2012 iPhone 5 with metal plates on
the back glass caps on the top and
bottom of the back and FaceTime camera
centered above the front speaker so
basically is this specific kind of like
yo we've got some extra pieces we want
to go back mm that's the iPhone se so
basically just sum it up it looks like
they're going to definitely be upgrading
the iPad air should we see if they wrote
anything what else we have try getting
so sidetracked in seven weeks
okay we've already we've discussed that
one probably nothing new since the last
time does a 4k display make sense for
iPad air 3 a bit far-fetched this rumor
could actually make sense the iPad Mini
has a sharper displayed in the air it's
smaller and a cheaper device the iPad
pro was actually pretty old it was
delayed because of elements of the
hardware software two companies chalice
was already failing Wow
wait when I don't care make awesome
stuff make me happy
sharper display is Apple selling point
here's the problems if you already have
like an iPhone 6s plus this thing is
massive it's really big
I don't even bother using my iPad
anymore because if I'm going to watch
show or I'm traveling I'm not going to
bring another device that I don't
actually need I do really like the iPad
pro that the stylus works with it but if
the stylus I'm sorry not stylus the
Apple pencil if that does work with the
iPad 3 that's great but honestly at this
point do you like do you need another
iPad do you need it I don't know that's
it
so iPhone 5se iPad air the new date for
the Apple announcement is March 25th
iPhone 7 I mean there's there's a lot of
stuff that's going to be coming out but
really what I am hoping for is a 4k
display hello we just work on that the
displays that they currently have are so
old they still look freaking great but
they've been out forever
I mean what you guys think in the
comments below what are you most looking
forward to what do you think about a
smaller 4-inch iPhone what do you think
about the headphone jack being removed
from the iPhone 7 and what do you think
about the iPad air do you care I don't
know I guess we'll find out I'll see you
guys later thanks for watching I'll see
you soon face if you look for really far
away like really far away it looks
pretty